le confinement un nouveau coup dur pour
les artistes qui viennent tout juste de
s'adapter au couvre-feu pour l'heure
dans le flou le milieu culturel n'est
pourtant pas surpris on s'en doutait un
an
on imaginait bien que ça n'allait pas
durer ce qui nous inquiète c'est en fait
de repartir peut-être un petit peu en
décembre pour qu'après en janvier et en
février on dise bas confie le problème
c'est qu'on a pas perspectives d'avenir
ça qui est inquiétant
hier devant l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre jean castex s'est dit
favorable au maintien des répétitions
tournage ou encore enregistrements une
décision qui rassure je vous en donne le
moral de pouvoir répéter quand même sur
la période
comme je disais du 16 au 20 novembre
pour prendre une semaine de répétitions
plus aboutir à une captation vidéo
autre inquiétude la marge de manoeuvre
pour créer de nouveaux projets culturels
est réduite
toutes ces mesures là je vois pas
comment il va y avoir de nouvelles
propositions de spectacles je me mets à
la place des investisseurs qui va créer
des nouveaux projets c'est trop
compliqué en ce moment donc là le 5 les
projets déjà existants si les artistes
peuvent répéter technicien continuer à
travailler
c'est une bonne chose mais pour l'avenir
jeu c'est compliqué moi je le vois dans
la vie de tous les jours au niveau des
habits d'audition enfin c'est normal
mais il ya plus rien donc ya pas
beaucoup de perspectives normal quoi
bilan les artistes yvelinois sont
solidaires et qu'on prenne les mesures
sanitaires
ils savent qu'ils vont devoir être
patient mais espère revenir sur scène
rapidement